welcome back this is the ben shapiro
show we're taking our calls at
855-236-3228 236 32
28 maxwell in new york you're on the
bench people should go for maxwell so my
question
has to do with actually my wife my
wife's uh uh pediatrician here in new
york and uh it seems like every day she
comes home
and talks about another kid who's either
attempted suicide or actually
successfully committed suicide
and she also discusses about how many of
her patients are
missing appointments uh medical
visits and if they're really causing
adverse effects
um i'm i have heard that your wife is
also a medical professional
i'm would be i would not be surprised if
she also comes home telling you stories
of this as well
i'm just wondering how come no one's
talking about this
well to talk about the various costs of
shutdown would of course be anti-science
that's the way this is this is
posited by the media if you talk about
the fact that there will be higher
suicide rates as a result of a bad
economy and by the way when when you're
talking about teenagers social isolation
which is not good for anybody if you
talk about the fact
that there are people who are losing
their incomes and their livelihoods and
that's going to lead to
depths of despair over time then this is
ignoring the science if you talk about
the fact that there is a
study out from the associated press
saying
that virus linked hunger has been tied
to 10 000 child deaths each month
that as the economy downturns and less
trade goes on that what you are seeing
is a shortage of food in places of the
area that are desperately poor
then that is apparently unworthy of
comment
you know all that stuff is unworthy of
comments according to many in the
mainstream media
and there's been some good research that
shows that there is likely to be
a pretty large surge for suicide and
this is not just in the united states
that there's going to be a suicide surge
internationally
as well there was during the spanish flu
too so my wife has been on medical
she's been on maternity leave because we
had a baby like one week before covet
hit the shutdown
um but the but the the stats are coming
in and they are very ugly there will be
significant social costs and cost to
life
if if the shutdowns continue this way
which is why i've been saying
socially distance wear a mask and let's
try and get people back to work
particularly if they don't have
pre-existing conditions we have to open
the schools again
we should be responsible in how we do
this none of this should be all that
controversial but the media have drawn a
false binary between we have to shut
everything in the world down and we have
to open everything in the world up and
unfortunately i think too many folks on
the right have bought into that as well
saying okay well basically everything is
fine no masks no social distancing enjoy
yourself
i don't think most people feel that way
i think most people are pretty unified
on this well
and you can see it and how people act
people shut down before the shutdowns
people started wearing masks before the
masculine mandates went out
yeah um i'm just wondering why uh like
trump and betsy devos for example don't
actually
push push this also as a narrative as
why kids need to go back to school
i mean i think that she has talked about
this i think she's talked about you know
the emotional problems listen i know a
lot of
parents who have kids who have you know
mild emotional issues
and they really need to be with other
kids like it's i know parents who have
kids
with with conditions like autism and
social isolation is not good for those
kids i mean it's really not i mean i i
know too many kids
who who suffer from conditions that are
really exacerbated
they see real regression in terms of
their ability to deal with with
mental and social conditions if they're
isolated and that's that needs to be
part of the conversation especially when
you're talking about risk to small
children that effectually does not exist
i mean there is no risk to small
children from this disease
on a statistical level you're talking
about death rates among small children
in the double digits in a country that's
had something like 400 000 infections
among
small children so you know all of that
should be on the table
but the media wish to push forward a
particular view and that view is is
basically that if you want to open the
schools you want to kill kids which is
utterly insane and not backed by the
data max well
really appreciate the call ethan and
louisiana you're on the bench bureau
shall go forward ethan
um i had a quick question i didn't make
22 year old male and
you know the biggest struggle i'm having
with a lot of people in my generation
is the fact that they're undereducated
and
they don't do their research on history
my i'm a right-wing conservative
one i do mostly everything you talk
about i agree with especially you know
debugging a lot of the
less liberal how would you say
i mean you you they'll say something to
you and then by the time you're done
talking to them their jaw will be to the
floor you know
that's just facts you know what is the
best thing
that i can do to educate them in regards
to you know hey don't buy this president
you know we need this free we need that
free we need that free first of all
nothing is free in this country
right it's either paid for by taxes they
already wanted to redistribute wealth
i'm personally i'm a first responder
so i see you know you've got these black
lives matter groups
first of all to me color race
religion and sexuality none of that
matters i have to remain impartial
because
and then i get backlash well why don't
you support this
why well but going back to my original
question
what is the best way i can educate
people in regards
to dismantling well when it comes to
this election
you're facing two obstacles one is lack
of knowledge about biden and the other
is
a perception of trump and that that's
very difficult i mean the latter one is
probably the harder one
lack of knowledge about biden can be
fixed by simply going through the
platform biden has said he's gonna raise
regulations biden has said
that he's going to significantly
undermine the economy through
really increased heavy increases
taxation increases
uh he has said that he wants to regulate
how businesses can operate none of that
is good for the economy and most
economists sort of agree with that i
mean the fact is that until covet hit
the economy is the best that it's been
in american history until until coveted
we had record low unemployment we had a
50-year high
in terms of employment and in economic
performance that's that's pretty good i
mean
that that was all good biden takes
precisely the opposite viewpoint so
it's not too hard to debunk biden's
platform the problem is people
feel non-threatened by biden because
biden is inherently sort of a
non-threatening creature he's sort of
just a political swamp thing
and people don't feel threatened by i
mean he's kind of senile he's he's
elderly
he doesn't seem like he's going to come
after you in any real way and you
juxtapose that with trump who appears to
be extraordinarily volatile and people
just
have this sort of innate reaction to
trump on a personal level that is very
difficult to overcome
and the point to make about trump is
that yeah trump does a lot of stuff he
says a lot of crap
tweets a lot of things but how much of
that translates into policy
and how much of his policy is actually
good and the answer there is that the
policy generally is pretty good
right when it comes to the economy
there's no question trump has said many
different conflicting things but when it
came to the economy the economy was
soaring up until covet when it comes to
the treatment of kovid the
administration has provided all of the
various democratic governors what they
need they have said this themselves
so yeah trump says dumb things sometimes
about covet that doesn't mean that what
the administration actually does
is dumb so you actually have to defend
is the constitutional boundaries that
hem
in the sillinesses of various presidents
not restricted to president trump that's
a bit of a hard pitch because people
tend to vote for people they don't tend
to vote for policies
if this were just a policy battle i
think republicans would almost innately
have an edge
but unfortunately this is not a policy
battle so that means that
as i've said many times the art of
politics is about making it hard to vote
for your opponent and easy to vote for
you
trump is fairly good at the first and he
is awful at the second if you are a
backer of president trump
then the burden then falls on you to
make it easier to vote for trump and it
seems to me the easiest way to get
people to vote for trump is to recognize
that voting for trump doesn't mean
voting for all of his various excesses
and sillinesses
it means voting for him as a bulwark
against the excesses and craziness of a
radical left
uh hopefully i'm not taking up too much
time here no go going back
i was appalled looking at the left side
in regards to everything i mean that's
supposed to just torque up
this entire what you should call that
festo speech whatever it's called
i think i was just full of opinions or
anything like that but
to me that's just un-american i've seen
more
yeah i mean again this all comes down so
much of this comes down to just per
pure personal hatred of trump which
means he has to make it easier for
people to like him
and easier for people to rally around
him so i agree with you that when she
rips up a speech that talks about record
low black unemployment for example
that's not a good look but the
mainstream media portrayed that as she
just doesn't like trump and when she
says everything in there was a lie
instead of saying okay so which things
were the lies
instead the media just says yeah because
trump's a bad orange man and that is
again why it comes down so much to
trump's personality he really needs to
hem himself
in and people who support him need to
make the case that personality foibles
do not mean bad president which
i think is is a plausible case to make i
mean bill clinton was filled with
personality foibles the left still loves
the dude so ethan appreciate
the call dominic in colorado you're on
the bench people should go forward
dominic
hey how's it going so um my first
question so my question is on
educat education because i think it is
the most integral part
of a healthy society and i feel like it
doesn't really get enough
um attention but first i'd like people
to know that they should research elijah
mclean because i was like one of the
most
like scariest things i've ever seen but
so for a public education system
um there's a issue with our schools like
area code funding
like keeping poor people in worse
schools uh teaching for tests and not
for conceptual understanding not
requiring classes like
philosophy or ethics or emotional
intelligence you know
the textbooks problems the history books
problems all that stuff
then i look at countries like south
korea with very cheap public education
they have a cultural respect for
teachers uh students are disciplined
they do their own dishes after lunch
uh you know european countries new
zealand singapore all have great systems
so if education is locally funded and
it's not
primarily federally funded how
how come we can't succeed like a
european country or south korea like
how do you see a realistic way forward
to fixing our schools
and how can we adopt what works
elsewhere and what can't we adopt
i mean just because it's america so the
reality is
that we can adopt most of the policies
that have been attempted in in various
places around the world i i really don't
think that that our public school system
is inherently problematic in terms of
the spending we have a few things that
are wrong with our public school system
one is
we have incentive structures that mean
that as you become more senior
in your union you get to move to a nicer
school which it should be precisely the
opposite we should have incentive-based
programs where if you're going into a
school
with kids who have more educational
difficulties you should be paid more for
that right if you're teaching in beverly
hills
actually should be paid less than if
you're teaching in south central los
angeles because if you're
because one is an easy school to teach
at the other is very difficult to teach
at
given the prevailing socioeconomic
circumstances that's that's issue number
one the bigger issue
is that when it comes to education this
has always been true
the reason that schools are good is
because the people who go to the schools
care deeply about education this is why
america
has the best college system on planet
earth but does not have a good public
education system below that because
people who go to college are
self-selected they're people who value
education they're willing to spend money
on education
and so to compare colleges to high
schools and junior highs and elementary
schools in the united states
it doesn't really you're comparing sort
of apples to oranges because of the
self-selection process
the same thing holds true of private
schools versus public schools private
schools outperform public schools
part of that is obviously the people who
are going to private school
happen to be richer but also it's
because people who are going to public
school
in some cases are not particularly rich
and they're on scholarship and their
parents have decided to dedicate a
significant portion
of their income to making sure their
kids get a good education so
the biggest imbalances in the
educational system
have to do with exactly the sort of
value systems that you're talking about
and again this is not based on color
there are real problems with this in
white appalachia for example appalachia
this is what jd vance talks about in
hillbilly elegy this exists in a variety
of communities
korean koreans in america do really
really well in school koreans in korea
do really really well
in school right jews in in europe do
really really well in school jews in
america do really really well in school
norwegians do really well in school in
the united states they do really well in
norway
the the idea that culture has nothing to
do with
the adoption of various attitudes
towards education it's just there's no
evidence to back that
so just tossing money at the problem
really isn't going to fix it you can
provide educational opportunity where
people who want to self-select
out of crappy public schools and be
surrounded by people who value education
that would be great right that's what
school vouchers would be for
that is what school choice would be for
charter schools right there are a
million kids waiting in line to get into
charter schools
and simultaneously democrats are trying
to shut down charter schools across the
country
right that's a disaster area so there
are certain things we can do to allow
people to self-select
out of out of schools where not enough
kids or parents take education seriously
that's the least we can do
but on a broad level if you want to help
the education system
there needs to there needs to be a
differential value put on education
in particularly dispossessed communities
that historically have have not done
particularly well in the educational
sphere
yeah okay i agree with you and the tier
system is terrible also because it's
it's similar to the military system
where it's like the longer you stay in
the more
you know pieces of paper you get the
higher you move up it's not based off of
like
actual data like how good your students
do that year and how good your students
do next year you know that should be
we should definitely use data for that
but um so yeah i guess that's the pickle
i'm in is
i know we we we have enough money um
that's not the problem there's a lot of
administration
and bureaucracy obviously that is
muddling that stuff but um
i guess yeah the biggest issue i guess i
have is like i didn't care about school
well i didn't care about my education
until after high school so after high
school i learned
i taught myself physics and quantum
physics and started learning about a lot
and like doing a lot of reading and
actually like educating and
caring about actual knowledge and but
then i you know
when i study other school systems it
seems like they like you said a cultural
reason so how do we why doesn't
government i guess
i guess i it's a question with
government like like the same thing with
chronovirus instead of saying like we
need to be healthier people
take you know fix your diet do zinc and
instead of like health care systems
being preventative and instead of
yeah i'm not sure how much of this
honestly i'm not sure how much this is
governmental people
like education but i really am not sure
how much of this is it can be solved by
government
united states in 2015 the united states
spent about 13
000 per student across the united states
on elementary and secondary education
in the oecd which are sort of the the
advanced countries the country average
is 9 500 bucks
so we are spending a lot of money on
education in this country the lie that
america is under spending
that's just not true dominic appreciate
the call we'll take more of your phone
calls in just one moment at 855 236 3228
that's 855
236 32 28 this is the bench bureau show